[Music]
hello and thank you for joining us I
know it's really late in the day but
we're so happy to see all of your faces
here my name is Sharon Harris
I am the VP of alliances at Deloitte and
I oversee our relationship with the
Google marketing platform and I am
thrilled today to be joined by my
partner and my technologist
extraordinaire mr. Matt major hi I'm
Matt major I'm a global partner
solutions lead on the Google marketing
platform and the ads products so today
we're going to share with you how the
Google cloud platform and the Google
marketing platform are coming together
and this is really exciting particularly
for US marketers because it's all about
how can we leverage this technology and
today we're going to look at it through
the lens of a marketer in the retail
space retail is an industry that's
really near and dear to my heart and
it's also an industry that's really
experiencing a ton of change a lot of
disruption and certainly it's under
siege you know whether you're a brick
and mortar store whether you're online a
mom-and-pop shop everyone is really
engaged in the battle today when it
comes to retail using retailers our
focus are really going to showcase the
power of marketing analytics on the
Google cloud platform and most
importantly what we now refer to as a
cloud for marketing so let's get started
I have this slide for a couple of
reasons
one when you think about at least 40% of
the businesses that we know today are
going to die in the next 10 years it's a
very ominous slide but I think it's
really important because it articulates
in a very clear way what's at stake I do
believe however it does provide an
insight into what we're going to talk
about today in that there's still hope
while we've seen many of our beloved
retailers fade away whether it's Brooke
stone or Henry Bendel or we've seen
stores clothes like pay less or Gymboree
Victoria's Secret there's still hope one
of my favorite retailers closed Toys R
Us I was really sad to see Geoffrey pack
his bags make that last exit out of the
store because that was the Fond part of
my childhood that was something just
aniconic brand for me everyone loved
Toys R Us but this quote really
symbolizes this is where we are right
now and this is really a critical
juncture if you're in the audience
saying you're working for a retailer or
you're a marketer this is really a
pivotal moment today now I've spent over
20 years in the marketing space a
variety of different roles and I can
tell you firsthand the job of a marketer
is very difficult you know the average
CMO their tenure is if they're lucky 18
to 24 months if you're not showing
results and those challenges are
continuing to evolve and they're new
concerns but they're new opportunities
at every turn top of the list of
challenges is how do you keep pace with
the technological change all of you are
here at Google cloud next because you
know what those next technological
changes are looking like and that's
really important and more and more
marketers are starting to come to the
table and understand how to leverage
that change but when you look at those
top five challenges we've got other
things to think about we've got to think
about how do we get the right talent in
our organization how do we create
engaging digital content how do we have
the right skills in our business and one
of my favorites is how do we measure the
effectiveness of digital content as a
marketer I can't manage what I can't
measure and that's really critical and
that's where once again the technology
can truly help me you know I was really
sad to see Sears file bankruptcy Sears
the original superstore the precursor if
you will to the Amazon Sears and iconic
American brand everything you wanted
from batteries two dresses two Kenmore
appliances
hires everything house to everything
under one roof Garanimals chubby can't
close everything you could possibly meet
under one umbrella that was the
destination for the family on the
weekends if your family was like mine
Sears we got the tires rotated got a new
battery picked up some clothes some
fabric even everything under that single
store I was really sad to see them say
farewell because it seemed to be the end
of a major era in our country but I say
this because I do believe that there is
still hope and today Matt and I are
gonna share with you some things that we
believe will help you to avoid some of
the pitfalls many of these other
retailers have experienced now it goes
without saying a key issue for a
marketer today is trust consumer trust
is paramount we've all heard the horror
stories of data breaches
you know the demise of many retailers a
lot of it's around
they didn't leverage their data and we
all know everyone in this room knows we
talk about data constantly data is the
number one strategic priority of
marketers and especially retailers data
is that new currency it's the new oil
it's the lifeblood of the organization
and if you don't really have a handle on
it you're not gonna be successful in
this current landscape now in
advertising we often say you know not
curing cancer I'm not making the world
safe for mankind
we're just making a heads unlike
physicians you know marketers we don't
take an oath but today I want us to take
an oath as a marketer the old fat want
you to take is really critical and it
goes like this as a marketer I vow to
know my customer be my customer and
empathize with my customer those are the
critical things you must do as a
marketer but of course you might be
asking yourself where do I begin
got lots of data lots of siloed data
I've got different organizations
different stakeholders I've got the
finance person breathing down my neck
going what are you spending all that
marketing money on you've got lots of
challenges that you're facing so where
do you begin the technology and
traditionally for marketers using Google
that technology has been the Google
marketing platform that's been the place
where marketers have gone to do the work
of knowing their customers and
empathizing with them better but they
haven't always been called that so who
here has used one of these products
before lots of hands
analytics DBM now DB 360 yes keep your
hands up if you have used more than one
of these products great so you know
already and most of you here have seen
or sit next to someone who does know
that these products have been loved and
used for years even though they haven't
been called the Google marketing
platform together marketing analytics
products can already share touch points
and behaviors in a privacy positive way
allowing brands to drive the relevance
that makes ads useful and build the
relationships that users need to ensure
that the brand stay top of mind
the unified Google marketing platform is
comprised of four products along media
buying ad serving and creative
management and for analytics products on
tag management site analytics data
visualization and web page optimization
this is the legacy analytics 360 suite
and the double-click platform together
these products make up the Google
marketing platform which is a really
great place to start to know and
empathize with your customers but the
Google marketing platform is really only
part of the picture I mean we're not at
GML if we take the ads data and the
marketing data alone we can only do so
much and for those of you who are
marketers
you're probably doing as much as you
already can what we need to do is we
need to use the data that's available to
do more interesting things more in-depth
things to know and to communicate better
with our customers think about the
business challenges you could solve if
you added your point-of-sale data to
your add behavior think about the
questions that your business is asking
you that you could answer if you just
had the CRM data and next to the ads
impressions how much more can you know
and empathize where their customer if
you just have more data connected we're
now at a point where CRM and offline
data like point-of-sale are in places
where they can be leveraged faster
together with ads and marketing data
they can really help tell both sides of
the business more things and help them
know and empathize with your customers
better the mark tech and the ad tech
side obviously will get a lot from this
but in time the production and supply
chain side will too so cloud and Google
marketing platform together make it
possible to be build better more
impactful campaigns and add vital data
to your CRM this enables a better
personalization strategy keeping users
engaged and connected and that ensures
that your data is in a private secure
place and is more thorough and of course
I think it's great I work at Google but
Sharon from your perspective why should
marketers care about Google marketing
platform and Google cloud together well
Matt it's super simple and it's simple
for everyone in this audience and be
started with the why 40% of all
businesses will die in 10 years the
stakes are high so when you think about
the Google cloud think about an open and
secure environment when it comes to
privacy and safety of consumer data you
can't afford anything less and if you
want to put your business at risk
because you've chosen a platform that
isn't open secure and safe good luck
know the customer we took the oath know
the customer be the customer empathize
with the customer
collecting and storing data in the cloud
allows for faster analysis which really
drives your decision-making process
remember you have hard dollars real
investments on the line if you're not
making the right decisions and choices
they can have catastrophic consequences
for your business today every second is
precious in this marketplace third
machine learning machine learning gives
you the ability to solve very complex
problems an ml is already a component of
the Google cloud platform so you can
easily leverage it to advance your
marketing capabilities and as a marketer
today you really want to be truly
data-driven so leverage ml so what does
that look like for those of you who like
to look at architecture and are pulling
their phones up now to take pictures of
it you've probably seen slides like this
already we can bring in data from the
Google marketing platform technologies
like Google Analytics 360 display in
video 360 and Google Ads like YouTube
and AdWords data this can all be stored
in bigquery storage and with bigquery
compute you can use cloud data lab and
cloud ml to run sequels to run sequel
queries and also to to create clusters
for advanced segmentation in terms of
visualization I think it's really
important to note that all of us don't
look at tabular data all the time it's
really important that for those who are
making decisions who aren't going to be
actually building out the data sets that
they understand what's actually
happening so building out a visual layer
is really important make it easy very
easy for the marketer you know I already
have a hard job I got 18 to 24 months to
show some results help me make the data
work for me that's really the key to
visualization so I'm happy you're doing
that for right and data studio is
awesome but some people like to use look
or a tableau great tools and so the
Google cloud platform allows you to
create visuals using any tool that you'd
like for those of us on the Google
marketing platform side once you
built out the clusters that you're
interested in using you can push those
in through what's called data import
into Google Analytics 360 to run ads on
display in video 360 or across the
Google ads products like YouTube or
search it's a really great way to very
easily leverage what you've already got
and do things that you can't do inside
of the user interfaces of those products
so on a high level a really easy example
of what we're doing together with
Deloitte today looks like this we start
with bigquery we use the most awesome
easy to use simple tons of connections
bigquery to take all of the data sources
that we have and put them together we
add in the display and video 360 data
using data transfer files as well as
Google adds data from YouTube and
Adwords and also there's a native
bigquery export from Google Analytics
360 that allows you to put that into
bigquery as well now for the client that
we have that we're already doing this
with they've got some data from
point-of-sales transaction and customer
databases that they wanted to add in so
we use data prep to structure that in a
way that can sit alongside the ads data
and then here's where the magic happens
yes you're pulling up your phones again
that's great we get two things out of
this once that data is structured and
put in a way that we can use it you can
get more analysis and activation out of
it and now for analysis it's important
to note that you can pass the audience's
back into the tools for measurement and
visualization you can also just pull
that into a visualization tool itself
and then for activation within the
Google ads products like Divi 360 and
ads for YouTube and search it's possible
to actually activate across segments
that you've built that have both the
display video 360 data the Google ads
data and also the behavioral data from
your site again this is a very basic
example even without getting into
machine learning or the AI part now
showing the real magic
so this is what people really think that
they need when they first start right it
needs to be super complex it needs to
solve all my problems it needs to solve
all of my challenges in every single
stakeholder from the CEO down to every
single coder needs to integrate be an
agreement before we can do this this is
something that Deloitte has already
suggested to some clients and I think
that we're going to be building it out
but it takes a long time to get the
stakeholders wrangled together empathy
is really complicated is what this says
very complicated so remember that
empathy is very very complicated but you
really can't start with this as a goal
this is too big to sell into all the
stakeholders necessary so we've always
suggested that you start with something
simple high value and scalable that way
teams can buy in on making the project
and the scope bigger and more complex
over time if you start with that first
slide you're gonna scare off a lot of
people and we don't have time to scare
people off we need to bring them in and
as a data-driven marketer you must prove
value with clear goals and you have to
have quick wins once again you're really
up against the clock so you want to make
sure that what you're delivering is
going to really work so the construct of
test and learn is key to help you close
those gaps now we're gonna take a look
at some examples of very very
straightforward retail client use cases
and as the marker there are some
frequent business problems that you're
trying to solve and we're always focused
once again what know the customer be the
customer empathize with the customer so
these fiber the highest historical
spenders in your business those
online-only shoppers you got to love
those folks heavy browsers that don't
log in so you're not getting any
authenticated data heavy couponers how
many people love coupons show of hands
that's it nobody likes to save money
come on get on the coupon bandwagon my
favorite is loyal customers that buy in
store and online I have to raise my hand
really high for that one because that is
me all day every day you two I knew it I
knew it so as we think about these use
cases these are really core to the
retail space and as we go through this
we're going to really focus on two and
the first which has really found a
foundational use case this is all about
how do you unlock the data that you have
so that you can start to control it you
can start to leverage it you can start
to really use it in your business this
is a critical step in the journey you
really can't go forward unless you have
this foundation built and this is all
about building an advanced data
infrastructure for media insights as a
marketer you're always asked am I
getting the value out of my media spin
that I should and I reaching the right
audience am i reaching them at the right
frequency is it with the right message
who knows and sometimes you really can't
ask your agency so what can you do to
really understand the performance of it
so Matt tell us what do we do well I can
tell you what you've done
Deloitte has done this for a marketing
already using data transfer files from
displaying video 360 they're using
bigquery and are and data visualizations
and business intelligence tools to
derive detailed media analytics so what
they've done is they've taken those data
transfer files and they've done with
them more granular insights than you can
get from the user interfaces of those
tools alone and then looking at that
granular data they have the ability to
more accurately look at media metrics
including reach and frequency this seems
like a base case because it is again we
wanted to start with something simple
scalable and of high value because this
provides the infrastructure to deliver
advanced media insights so again we're
suggesting for you to start with
something simple and foundational prove
your case right bring people over that's
really critical and so the value that is
derived from doing this as you're
traveling from the left side to the
right side data comes internets
structured or its structured but not in
a way that's congruous with the rest of
the data that you have and as we provide
more and more structure and more and
more details emerge we can start to get
more and more insights so things like
understanding cross campaign conversion
and user overlap is kind of basic but as
you get a quick win you get more teams
bought into it and then you can start
doing more advanced things like trending
and analytics and visualizations off of
what you've already built and then
starting to get into predictive
analytics customer lifetime value churn
propensity etc and then you then you get
to start doing activation at scale I
mean the true the true goal here is to
be able to do things quickly scale ibly
and automate it if you can again this is
the base case for really anything
including our second use case which is
all about data-driven segmentation now
when you think of data-driven
segmentation as a marketer yes you want
to know your customer but you need to
know is this the loyal customer is this
a new customer you want to understand
can I discover new customers because
that's ultimately the real prize and
wouldn't be segments and categorized
customers that really drives our
decision-making process and it
ultimately leads to greater efficiencies
which give you stronger returns so Matt
once again how are we gonna pull this
off
so if you remember that old slide
collect cluster visualize and activate
it's almost the same story but what we
can do is we can take that point-of-sale
data along with site analytics and CRM
data and run machine learning clusters
on it to find meaningful behavioral
insights so identifying user attributes
of each cluster that when users show up
and behave in certain ways that we can
then put them quickly into a segment
that might be able to be activated or at
least be visualized so we can start
looking at trends and then finally
activating those clusters when possible
for media buying and displaying video
360 Google ads or other media channels
so let's look an example of how we might
apply that to an actual user situation
and because it was just her birthday
we've named my hypothetical user on my
mom Audrey
unfortunately we couldn't bring Audrey
with us today but he's here with us in
spirit cheering her beautiful son Matt
on it would be a much longer session if
she was here anyway so we're gonna say
that Audrey just went on line and went
to an electronics retailer and bought a
camera now she might shop at that
electronics retailer online pretty often
so we might have some CRM data about her
and we have the G a 360 purchase data
and maybe some behavioral data so we
have some insights already now with
display and video 360 or with other
activation channels we could do things
like sending her ads for the accessories
that she might need for that camera or
suggesting that she bundled together
memory cards but that's kind of all we
can do I'd say things related to exactly
what you're doing right now but if we're
adding things like machine learning
tools across our entire CRM and across
all of the behavioral insights that we
can pull we can cluster Audrey or my mom
into a group of people who are frequent
travelers so we start getting insights
about people who have bought cameras but
I've also bought things like
international chargers or lots of
different cords for things because they
lose them and we know that people who
are frequent travelers don't just buy
cameras they also buy noise cancelling
headphones who has noise canceling
headphones who travels a lot yeah
exactly
that kid in the fourth row you know who
I'm talking about anyway so the reason
that that's important is because then we
can start segmenting out users who've
done some of the things that we're
interested in but not all of them so we
take this user Audrey we start to
cluster users like her that have done
things like bought a camera are
identified as a frequent traveler but
haven't bought those headphones and then
we can tailor ads to those people
specifically like showing them ads
specific to your frequent traveler
Audrey we know you bought this camera
and here's some headphones you might
want to
Adri seeds an ad she's a higher
likelihood of buying those those
headphones before her next trip or if
you know you're a really good son
Mother's Day is approaching sounds like
a good gift for mom I want to I want her
to hear when I call so today we've
walked through architecture and examples
of two really important use cases to
bring together Google cloud and Google
marketing platforms to help you know and
empathize with the people who matter to
you most your customers the better
together story is about doing that at
the pace of change of the industry your
business and the people who are buying
you and keeping you alive without a
doubt you know we hope the information
that we share today from the perspective
of a marketer and retail and of course
the technologists have somehow been
enlightening to you you know I
absolutely love technology but what I
love more is what a technology allows me
to do I like it to be actually seamless
and in the background because I want to
be the person in control and for
marketers and especially retailers
Google Cloud gives you that speed and
privacy and security
to do what know your customer be your
customer empathize with your customer
secondly predict marketing outcomes you
want to know where the puck is going you
don't want to be where it is you want to
be ahead of those trends and as a
retailer and a marketer whatever your
product is you need to have that ability
so you can harness the technology to
help you do that and then thirdly
personalized experiences consumers are
demanding more and more personalizations
we want ads products and experiences
that are relevant to us that speak to us
that's really critical so if you don't
take anything away from what we've
talked about today take away these three
things when you think about the Google
cloud know your customer predict those
marketing outcomes and personalize those
experiences on a platform that gives you
greater speed privacy and security now
we've empowered all of you with this
great information so you can be change
agents in your organization and that's
not a difficult task change is always
hard but it all begins with something
very simple it's called the conversation
you know it's always like when your
significant other says you know we need
to talk let's have a talk or
conversation those things can be
challenging but for an organization the
biggest hurdle is really around shifting
mindset evolving the culture of the
organization can sometimes be your
number one obstacle you know having
those conversations early and often is
really key because you've really got to
work to break down the silos in
marketing and technology and sales and
operations and finance because
ultimately every single aspect of the
business is made better when you come
together and if you don't it's kind of
clear what's gonna happen exactly but
there is hope you know if we think about
the brands like the Sears and the Toys R
Us is of the world they may what they
could have done with their data you know
had they used these kinds of
technologies or if they had been
available to them we may not have to say
goodbye to Geoffrey you know think about
it
those are real real consequences of when
you're not leveraging the technology and
the other thing that goes kind of
without saying is that we need partners
and marketers and Google and other
ecosystem players involved to get this
done we need especially strong partners
to be able to help marketers through
these challenges both with the
communication part of it and the
delivery itself I mean that's slide the
really complicated one very few
marketers can do that by themselves some
can but very few can do it so we need
partners that are really enabled and
able to do this and I want to say thank
you to you Sharon for being such a great
partner and thank you to Matt for being
my technologist extraordinaire at Google
but you know we hope you've enjoyed this
presentation we knew it was the end of
the day so we weren't gonna keep you the
entire 50 plus minutes this we're
standing probably between food cocktails
music what-have-you but we hoped you
found this valuable and we're happy to
take your questions and you know both
Deloitte and Google are here to help but
before you exit we do have something to
ask of you your feedback complete the
survey session in the mobile app and of
course is Matt shamelessly says five
stars is always better than one but we
would love to hear from you so if
anyone's got any questions yep there are
a couple of microphones here and I know
that we don't have anything on the Dory
right now thank you so much for your
time today I got a question
that's curious about it well the Google
whatever tools you guys provide to
enable marketer to run experiments I'm
sorry can you repeat that what kind of
tools do you have to enable marketing
team to run experiments try to
understand the customers you need to run
experiments so there are a couple of
different kind of experiments that you
might be talking about and some are on
the website so if it's a web experiment
there's optimized 360 there's a free
version of optimized as well you can
take a look at that that can actually if
you're using the Google Analytics 360
product you can take audiences directly
from Google Analytics and push those in
to optimize 360 for tests it's a really
great product it's not as used as some
of the other GA 360 suite products but
it's really excellent I suggest you try
it in terms of other testing scenarios
there are some within the ads products
and you'd have to ask someone within
cloud who can give you more just follow
up on that do you have any optimization
tools across channels not to stay of my
turf or websites or apps do you have
some sort of cross channel optimization
tools that that's basically what I'm
asking for so currently I'm not aware of
a cross channel optimization tool there
were some technologies within the app
mission 360 tool originally that were
slated to do that but that is not
currently an available product if you
could talk a bit about how you think
privacy and interests of customers in
terms of having more privacy or maybe
control of their data and how that might
affect the marketing ecosystem oh sure I
mean you know data is definitely in
privacy as a hot topic I think first and
foremost as a marketer you need to
understand consent consumer consent is
everything so if you're collecting data
and it's important to have your own
first party data make sure you have the
right consents that's gonna be key and
then once again it needs to be first
party data you know we talk a lot about
data breaches and a lot of that stems
from the fact that many marketers and
many brands don't really own their own
data they've got their data siloed it's
across different platforms they've got
different agencies in there so they
don't really have great visibility nor
transparency into what's happening but
there are a couple of things that I
really stress to people today pay
attention to the regulations we already
have GDP are in Europe we have CCPA or
the California Consumer Protection Act
that's about to be ratified here those
are really gonna be game changers for
how you think about the collection and
storage of data so first party data is
really critical and because if you don't
have it the penalties for those data
breaches are not just the loss of your
customers but also some pretty hefty
fines thank you very much for speech as
far as we know a user ID is unavailable
on data transfer files from double-click
so that's correct yep so did you make
this case before those limitations No
so the thank you for those of you who
are who are not aware data transfer
files as we've described from the
displaying video 360 product and
campaign manager product do not include
user ID so the full cookie store
information however that information can
be can be used not necessarily joined
directly to the GA 360 data but also
things like time stamping or other
predictive cases can allow you to still
get insights from there is also an
additional product set that could
potentially solve some problems or
questions about data transfer files that
are missing user ID fields and that's
something that you should talk to your
Google team about one more there some
more oh hi jack hi Matt Matt and Sharon
thanks very much first of all for
sharing all this very helpful really
appreciate the fact that this might be
one of the first examples I've seen
where Google cloud platform is being
Illustrated as an integral part of the
solution that the Google marketing
platform can deliver so congratulations
on the one Google theme here it's also
affirming to show that disparate data
can be consolidated to create better
audiences my question is will we be
seeing more of that will we be seeing
more of one Google where the Google
cloud platform becomes a foundation for
the great work that you guys do on the
GMP side I think it's pretty safe to say
that yes we'll be seeing were that what
that will look like from from day to day
quarter to quarter year to year may
change but I think everyone on both the
clouds and the GMP side know that we
need each other to be able to answer the
fundamental questions and challenges
that marketers have today
good looking forward to seeing it thank
you well thank you very much everyone
for coming today Thank You Sharon
thank you enjoy the rest of your cloud
next
[Applause]
[Music]